nous avons appris la semaine dernière
par la bouche de sa présidente que
l'unef organiser des réunions interdites
aux blancs cette forme d'apartheid
cette forme d'apartheid constitue une
étape supplémentaire dans la longue
dérive immonde de ce syndicat déjà des
responsables de cette organisation
déclarée en 2017 vouloir gaz et où les
blancs 7 sous race ou encore parler de
délire de petits blancs après l'
incendie de notre dame
plus grave encore récemment ce syndicat
livré au loup et mettez leur vie en
péril à deux enseignants de l'iut de
grenoble oubliant ce qui avait provoqué
la décapitation de samuel bâti très
clairement aujourd'hui
l'unef a quitté le champ républicain
pour devenir le bras armé de l'islam y
de l'islamo gauchisme à l'université
vous devez vous devez monsieur le
premier ministre en tirer toutes les
conséquences j'ai entendu des
condamnation claire et sans équivoque de
ces comportements insupportables dans
votre gouvernement et je les salue
notamment de la part du ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais j'ai entendu
aussi des propos beaucoup plus ambigu
notamment de la part de madame moreno ce
matin qui critiquait lebel ministre de
l'éducation nationale le racisme le
racisme et la haine ne peuvent se
condamner à moitié mais question seront
donc simple
entendez vous oui ou non engager la
dissolution de l'unef
entendez vous supprimez tout financement
public de l'unef
entendez vous saisir le parquet pour
qu'une procédure judiciaire soit ouverte
pour incitation à la haine raciale